In this part of level editing,
I want to talk about building the mini-map.
Now, there are a couple of things that we need to do
in order to get our world partition mini-map to work.
And that setup's actually fairly easy.
It just is not well known.
And the one thing that we really need to do
is put in something called
the world partition mini-map volume.
Once you place this into our level,
we should scale it to the size of our landscape.
And this is really gonna help us ensure
that we are only capturing the area that we want.
Inside of our world partition mini-map
that is placed inside of our level, we can select that
and then we're gonna have a bunch of different options.
Under here, we have things like our world unit per pixel
or which allows us to increase or decrease
the size of the capture and world units
that we are going to capture.
We then have our builder cell size
which allows us to adjust the size of the individual grids
that are used when we grid this up
and build the sections for it
as this isn't built as one giant texture
but it is built with virtual textures in mind.
So it is built in quadrants
and then streamed in as one massive texture.
Underneath build cell size, we have capture source
which allows us to do many different things.
You notice that it is a dropdown menu.
And from this menu,
we can select a whole bunch of different options
in terms of how the mini-map texture is actually output.
Last but not least, we have capture warmup frames.
And if you notice, this is actually set to 10
in this example.
This allows things like world partition,
Nanite and other systems time to stream in
and warm up as the capture happens
and eliminates seams that could be shown
inside the ending artwork.
So let's pop over to the editor now
and check out how this works.
So first off, what we're gonna do
is I have a world partition mini-map here.
So this is the mini-map
and this is gonna be added by default.
But what we need to do is come in here
and add a mini world partition mini-map volume.
And for me, what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to zero this out
and then I'm gonna hit F to kind of focus in on this.
And we want this to cover our entire massive landscape.
So we're gonna scale this thing.
Actually, I'm probably gonna do something like this.
And let's do, well, probably need to be like 5,000,
I think.
Well, 5,000 is a little bit too much.
So let's just scale this back in.
We'll say like 2,500
and keep scaling this in just a little bit.
We want it right on the edges there.
Looks about right, so about 2,000
and then we're gonna do the same thing over here.
So probably just scale this out to 2,000.
And then here, we're gonna do like 500
and we wanna make sure that,
yeah, that looks about good.
We wanna make sure that this is not,
there's nothing like sticking out
or sticking not covered by the volume
of bottom of the volume,
but also nothing not covered by the top.
We don't want like this part of the landscape
sticking out of the top or it'll get cut off.
We wanna make sure everything is inside of there.
So there we go.
We have that all set up.
This is great.
So the next thing that we're gonna do
is we're gonna come down to our,
or I shouldn't say come down,
but we're gonna locate our World Partition Minimap.
There we go.
And then what I'm gonna do is say my warmup features,
I'm gonna set this to 10.
And right now I am just going to come up here
and do a build
and we're gonna do World Partition Editor Minimap.
And so I'm gonna save all this
and we will be right back once this builds
because this will take a second
the first time we do a build here.
All right.
So our build is done now.
So if I click over to World Partition, check this out.
This is what we have right here.
So this is actually this house that's right over here.
Wait, where'd the house go?
I can't even find it.
So let's just go like this and go move camera here.
There we go.
So that's our house.
So there we go.
And if we come back to our World Partition Minimap,
there's a couple of other things in here.
So notice we have this excluded data layers.
If we were to add another element here
and we are not actually using any data layers
in this project
but what we could do is the data layers that we do use
we could use these to exclude that particular content.
So if we know that we don't want something
on the World Partition Map, we can exclude that here.
One of the other things that we can do again
is change our world units per pixel
and our builder cell size to give us increased
or decreased resolutions.
I'm gonna actually set this to 20
and then I'm gonna come here
and I'm actually gonna change this
to my final HDR and linear color space.
I do believe actually, nope, I'm sorry.
Take that back.
We're gonna do this scene color.
This is the one I think in RGB and opacity in A.
There we go.
This one right here, sorry about that.
And then we're just gonna come up here to build
and we are going to build
our World Partition Minimap Editor.
So just save that real quick
and we will be right back once this builds
to see the difference.
All right, so our level is done.
Let's pop over to our World Partition
and we can see here, we've got a couple of changes
and now we're seeing some more interesting details
inside of here.
So we've got some shading from our house here
and different shading from our environment.
One of the other cool things,
if we hit Control-Alt-L and we kind of adjust this,
maybe we give it some longer shadows,
we're actually gonna see this reflected
inside of our build here
because the light that is captured for this
is actually directly captured from the level
and that is to change that if you don't want that,
that is where if we come here
to get into our World Partition Minimap
and then change our capture source,
we can adjust this accordingly to what we want.
So that is how we utilize building our mini maps
so that we can have a great representation
of what's going on inside of our level.
I'll see you in our next lesson.